pour one out for Game of Thrones because
winter has finally come for the most
popular TV show in recent history but
before you start crying over the fate of
your beloved characters remember that
for the show's actors there's life after
death
here's a look at what the Stiles behind
these Dead Game of Thrones characters
look like today
Ross went from being a northern
prostitute to Littlefinger's trusted
assistant at one of his King's Landing
brothels but her increased station came
with a price
Littlefinger discovered that she was
spying on him for Varys so he gave it to
Joffrey nor lended quite brutally for us
he was bound to Joffrey's bed frame and
killed with several crossbow bolts in
season three since I gruesome thrones
demise actress as Mae Bianco was
appeared in the TV movies a Christmas
mystery and ominous as well as the
television series The Magicians a recent
film projects include hypnotized about
people being trapped under hypnosis
while the hypnotist falls into a coma
and the found-footage vampire thriller
living among us the red Viper Oberyn
Martell traveled to King's Landing in
hopes of finding answers regarding the
death of his sister Elia Oberyn got more
than he bargained for when he
volunteered to fight for Tyrion during a
trial by combat against Gregor in season
four he got the answer he wanted but
Gregor smashed his face like a grape not
long after since thrones actor Pedro
Pascal has starred in Graceland
narcos the Great Wall and Kingsman the
Golden Circle his star power is only
continuing to rise as he prepares to
take the title role in the Disney Plus
Star Wars series the mandalorian and an
as-of-yet unidentified part and Wonder
Woman 1984 the kiss by firewalling
Ygritte played by Rose Leslie entered
into a passionate romance with Jon Snow
but it wasn't meant to be
Jon abandoned her and was later forced
to watch her struck down in the season 4
battle between their forces you know
nothing
leslie has kept busy since leaving Game
of Thrones continuing her role in
Downton Abbey and starring in the last
witch hunter
Leslie and Thrones co-star Kit Harington
also became romantically involved after
she left the series culminating in their
Summer 2018 wedding her recent projects
include a main role in the CBS legal
drama the good fight Barristan Selmy
made his way across the sea to join
Daenerys Targaryen as one of her closest
advisors during that time in Mereen the
elusive sons of the harpy lay an ambush
for the unsullied in season 5 killing
many before Samaritan arrived he took
out nearly a dozen enemies
single-handedly saving grey worm a but
died in the effort despite being upset
about beerus turns early demise star Ian
McElhinney has moved on with his career
appearing in Derry girls rebellion and
rogue one a Star Wars story he can
currently be seen as scientist Val on
Syfy Superman series Krypton
Sana's his daughter Shireen had royal
blood which is why Melisandre insisted
on bringing the child with them when
Stannis's army marched to Winterfell
unfortunately Shireen didn't live to see
the end of that March she was sacrificed
by the red priestess in season five when
Melisandre convinced Stannis and his
wife to that's a burn Shireen at the
stake for a blessing from the Lord of
lights after her carrot says horrible
fate on Game of Thrones young actress
Carrie Ingram moved on to other
television roles she's appeared in the
show's Wolf Hall doctors and barbarians
rising and can currently be seen in the
Netflix original series free reign
Stannis sacrificed his daughter to gain
the blessing of the Lord of lights the
blessings weren't exactly what he
received in return his wife took her own
life half of his army deserted him and
all of his forces were stolen the
remnants of his forces were easily swept
away by the Bolton army and the defeated
Stannis was killed by prayin during the
season 5 finale since Game of Thrones
actor Steven Delaine has appeared on the
television show the tunnel and in films
like Mary Shelley and he also made an
appearance on his hit Netflix
biographical series the crown as well as
a youngest star child
Rickon didn't get a lot of screen time
before he and OSHA separated from branch
group in season 3 they reappeared in
season 6 as captives of Ramsay Bolton
and drawing the Battle of the Busters
Ramsay set Rick on free telling him to
run to Jon before firing on the boy he
nearly made it but one of Ramsay's
arrows struck killing wreck on art
Parkinson has scored several
since leaving Thrones including his 2016
stint voicing the title role in the
animated film cube oh and the two
strings and an appearance in the movie
Zoo he can currently be seen on the UK
police procedural series the bay
beginning in season 3 Ramsay Bolton
shocked Game of Thrones fans with his
cruelty on a regular basis and
eventually as viewers knew it would it
all caught up with him following
Ramsay's two feet at the Battle of the
Busters in season six
it looks like Jon Snow might beat him to
death but he held off giving the honours
to assist a Sansa who made use of the
loyal dogs Ramsay had been starving for
seven days given the chance to take a
bite of their masters bloody face they
tucked right in he won we on starkest
soared since Thrones he's appeared in
several shows including us Maximus on
the Marvel series Inhumans in 2019 he
appeared in Netflix's motley crue biopic
at the dirt as guitarist Mick Mars the
politically savvy and whip-smart
Margaery Tyrell nearly managed to
resolve her family's issues with a faith
and fortunately no one heeded her
warnings about the lengths Cersei would
go in order to protect her son he
understands the consequences of her
absence and she is absent anyway which
means she does not intend to suffer
those consequences wait little scene
from the season 6 finale Margaery and
much of our family along with the high
Sparrow were consumed alive by wildfire
after Cersei put her plan in motion
recently actress Natalie Dormer lent her
voice to the 2017 game a Mass Effect
Andromeda and appeared in the miniseries
Picnic at Hanging Rock and the films in
darkness and patient zero next she'll be
seen in the penny dreadfuls spin-off
City of Angels and heard in the Dark
Crystal Age of resistance Netflix's
prequel to Jim Henson's fantasy classic
Tommen Baratheon became an unlikely King
when he succeeded to the throne after
Joffrey died at the purple wedding after
witnessing his mother blow up the Sept
of Baelor
killing his wife and all others inside
Tommen jumped from a balcony in the red
keeper during the season 6 finale
since the parting game of Thrones young
star Dean Charles Chapman has booked
roles in the film's breathe and the
commuter as well as a regular role on
AMC's into the Badlands Dame Diana Rigg
was already an acting legend thanks to
roles and films like on a Majesty's
Secret Service and TV series are the
Avengers when she arrived on Game of
Thrones but she quickly carved out yet
another legendary role for herself as a
wit
and dangerous queen of thorns lady
Olenna Tyrell when she finally met her
end in the season 7 episode the Queens
justice she was a last remaining major
player in her house and she'd already
done plenty of damage to the Lannisters
as Jaime Lannister forced her to drink
poison rather than be tortured she dealt
one last blow and admitted she was the
one who poisoned his son Joffrey at his
own wedding
I wanted to know it was me
since exiting Thrones rigours continued
to act most recently as the duchess of
per clutch in the hit TV series victoria
aiden Guillen's Littlefinger remained
among Game of Thrones as longest-serving
and most frustratingly capable survivors
rights up until the end of season 7 when
one of the great schemers and Westeros
finally met his end he seized power in
the Eyrie one favour with Sansa Stark
and then very nearly managed to turn the
stark children against each other and
they were all finally reunited at
Winterfell then at long last Arya and
Sansa revealed that they had
Littlefinger right where they wanted him
and Arya executed in with his own dagger
it was one of the show's most satisfying
deaths and the end of one of the show's
most persistent villains thank you for
all your many lessons Lord Baelish
we'll never forget them gilens been in
high demand ever since his work in the
days of the wire and that hasn't changed
since he left thrones as he was ending
his time on that series he joined the
acclaimed series peaky blinders played a
role in Bohemian Rhapsody and continued
his work in The Maze Runner franchise in
January 2019 his new series Project Blue
Book about the US government's hunt for
UFOs premiered on the History Channel
the merriest and was one of the three
son snakes who helped ilaria sand seize
and hold power in Dorne after the death
of a father Oberyn Martell unfortunately
for her she and her sister uber were
abruptly killed at the violent hands of
euron greyjoy the last time we seen her
Miriah she strung up by her own weapon
the bow of your own ship star Jessica
Henrik has only become more prominent
since her character's death though in
2017 is a time when throne was ending
she started playing martial artist and
teacher Colleen wing on the Netflix
series iron fist she also appeared as
Colleen in a cameo appearance in the
second season of Luke Cage and played a
major role in the crossover event at the
defenders her next major franchise
project has a role in Godzilla vs. Kong
scheduled to be released in 2020
Benjen stark has one of the more
interesting arcs on the course of Game
of Thrones as run after appearing early
in the first season and welcoming his
nephew John's of the Nights Watch benjin
ventures out behind the wall and isn't
the heard from again until season six
when he reveals to his nephew bran Amira
Reed he's now undead having been stabbed
by the White Walkers and then brought
back from the brink by the children of
the forest he was never fully converted
into a white which means he can fight
for the living but he's far too gone to
cross back over the wall and pass
through as many enchantments so he does
what he can from the far north in season
7 that includes sacrificing himself for
the whites to save John ending his watch
once and for all
outside of Game of Thrones actor Joseph
Moore's Korea continues to gain traction
he was cast as Odysseus in the 2018 TV
series troy full of a city he can also
be seen as George Orwell in the
biographical drama mr. Jones and
alongside Richard Gere in the British
drama series mother father-son the
middle seasons of Game of Thrones told
among other things the story of the
North's disintegration into chaos as the
largest of the Seven Kingdoms shifted
from steadfast bastion of honour and
durability to a Bolton led man
when John and Sansa finally started
putting the North back together under
stark banners they met Lyanna Mormont a
pint-sized lady of Bear Island who
ultimately proved to be one of the most
effective and unflinching leaders the
show has ever seen in her final days the
ana refused to hide from the fight
against the dead opting to lead her men
rather than take shelter from the battle
and she went down like a bus stabbing an
undead giant in the eye as he crushed
her Game of Thrones was a Wells
introduction to younger Bella Ramsay and
her acting career has steadily gained
momentum ever since a debut on the show
in 2016
her other credits now include the title
roles in the TV series Hilda and the
worst witch and this year she'll also
co-star in two period drama films the
Judy Garland biopic Judy and the World
War Two drama resistance check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more loop of videos but your
favorite stars are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and to the bail
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]